(mysterious music)
- [Voiceover] C-sections are
the most common major surgery
performed on human beings.
Over basically one generation of moms,
the C-section rate has gone up by 500%.
The problem is that
your number one risk for
having a C-section might be
which hospital you go to.
That's what wakes me up in the morning.
(mysterious music)
I'm Neel Shah, an obstetrician over at
Beth Israel Deaconess Medical Center.
I'm an assistant professor
at Harvard Medical School,
and I'm part of the core
faculty here at Ariadne Labs.
A lot of people don't
realize the full magnitude
of the problem with C-sections.
Basically, in the late 1960s, early 1970s,
C-section rates were about five percent.
Then all of a sudden, the C-section rate
starts to skyrocket.
Not just increase, but skyrocket.
So, before the end of the century,
the C-section rate goes
up to one in three.
And we don't really have a great
idea why this is happening.
As a surgeon myself, it's hard to believe
that one in three human beings needs
major surgery to be born.
But that's sort of where we are right now.
And the consequences are significant.
So, things like severe
infection, hemorrhage,
organ injury, in addition to
five billion dollars of spending annually,
we're talking something like 20,000 major,
avoidable surgical
complications that we're seeing
from C-sections we didn't
need to do in the first place.
I was really puzzled when
I first started this job,
thinking like, what can
we possibly do about this.
Epidemiologists,
economists, policy makers,
lots of people have
been thinking about this
for a long time.
The clue for me was the
fact that across country,
C-section rates vary from seven
percent to 70% by hospital.
If hospital performance is so uneven,
and it's not explained by patient
risk or patient preference,
that means the hospital
itself could be a risk factor.
All of our projects right
now are actually trying to
figure out what makes hospital
A different from hospital B.
(electronic music)
What we've seen is that often times the
labor floor is in kind of like an
almost forgotten about corner and
it just doesn't get a lot of investment
or attention from the hospital.
When we visit a bunch
of different hospitals,
we realized that they're
laid out very differently,
and that might matter.
For example, there are
no rules for how many
labor floor rooms you should have
based on the amount of
patients that you see.
The place that does
twice as many deliveries
also does way more C-sections.
The only way that's possible is if they're
moving people through much faster.
Almost all labor floors seem really
tight on resources, so
the idea is when you have
a huge surgeon patient volume, how do you
flexibly recruit more rooms?
How do you bring in more staff?
You report C-section rates
back to your doctors.
Like, I have no idea what my C-section rate is
until somebody tells me.
Now we're testing this hypothesis
that management matters
in childbirth just the way it matters
in every other industry.
We're starting to parse
differences among C-sections.
So, rather than looking at
all C-sections all together,
we're trying to just take
the lowest risk women
and focus on their C-section rate.
As soon as you start to do
that, two things happen:
Insurance companies
start to pay attention,
and then, just women
start to pay attention.
And I actually think this is an area where
women's views on this are probably
going to be the driving
force behind the change.
There's really no other
moment in people's life
where they're so discerning
as when they become pregnant.